so I think it's time to settle the case
of R versus python I won't settle it it
will be settled by the Belgian justice
department so let the battle begin um
the Belgian justice department had an
urgent need for a traffic fine
monitoring system and both R and python
were actually on the table
who am I I'm Thomas Mitchum uh a data
science lead at axi axi is a It software
and full service posit partner in
Belgium and in the Netherlands here
we're also known for the donuts at our
booth uh we actually settled another
battle there the Battle of Dunkin Donuts
versus St Donuts I'm happy to announce
that St Donuts one
today my background is I started as an
analyst then turned architect then
turned a data
scientist I learned python from my
fellow developers and I learned R from
business experts so a little bit
different um and last year uh our
company also gave a a battle
presentation it was then shiny versus
powerbi but so this year our versus
python so axi as a It software company
is actually also responsible of building
the traffic fine processing system in
Belgium uh so the traffic fine
processing system it's a complex system
with many actors involved uh the Easy
Flow is just the police departments send
fines to the Fine processing system who
then send the file to The Postal Service
who prints these fines that deliver them
to civilians who then make payments that
are matched Again by the fine processing
system each time I get a traffic fine in
the mail I get to thank the company I
work for
but for the case let's uh we'll have a
look at the judge so what the Belgian uh
justice department does we'll have a
look at the suspects who has a say in R
versus python uh there's two important
investigations who can deliver the
quickest and also who is the best fit
for production uh and in like in any
case we'll have a see if we can make any
kind of mediation if a settlement is
possible and then we'll come to the
verdict so the Belgian justice
department department so they are among
many things responsible of overseeing
the traffic fines it's actually quite a
large scale operation so the collection
from traffic finds in Belgium alone
exceeds $500 million annually so it's
actually quite a large number so making
mistakes can cost them a lot of money uh
but it's also very reputational thing
where civilians really don't like to get
fins and they even like it less if they
get it a fine twice if they pay it twice
so it's a process that
needs to be uh looked at and um there
were some issues with the the process
and the justice department needed a
monitoring tool to actually help smooth
that uh
process and then RM python came to the
table so there's languages that can be
used not only for machine learning but
also in a broader
context but of course people are already
a bit biased if they uh hear the both
languages R and python
some people if they think of R they see
it as a specifically statistical
language so it's sometimes seen as good
for trivia questions like how many
people do you need in a room to get a
50/50 chance that two people have the
same
birthday does anybody in the audience
know3
33 23 okay 23 is the right answer of
course never let anybody say that it's
something else python is the developer
language it's for the whes space
enthusiasts that make sure that their
indentation is always correct it's for
Zen lovers that when they type import
this they get a whole Zen poem and it
can be used for anything not just data
science so already from the start
there's different
opinions but let's do some
investigations who can deliver the
quickest because there was quite an
immediate concern there had been some uh
glitches in the system where uh the
justice department needed a solution
quickly and overhauling the operational
system would take a couple of months so
there was a lot of process around making
changes to that uh system so it was not
something that they could quickly
fix and so that's where the requirement
came for a flexible monitoring tool to
have a look at uh anomaly detection also
inspecting file contents and uh many
more things and that solution needed to
be there
fast and python was actually the
quickest out of the gate so the most of
the stakeholders were already on board
with uh python we had the IT department
that already had some uh data processing
Solutions in uh Python and also some of
the checks for example for the uh
Financial files the payment files uh
were already available as a python
package so something that
the open source Community is really uh
good at in building already packaged
Solutions and so if python would have
been chosen then or at least these
things would have been developed already
quickly but we made counter where we
used chiny to build a quick UI mockup a
quick UI demo actually uh for the actual
users of the system uh we started this
project in 2020 so there was no shiny
for python yet so it had good old
classic R
shiny and uh there was only one
requirement by the end users they wanted
to see traffic lights if they looked at
the monitoring so we gave them uh
traffic lights so a dashboard where they
could see in the color if things are
running smoothly if there are any issues
until to drill down into uh what is uh
happening so the back office was already
uh on
board and also for the case of R there
were some Auditors uh one of the big
four uh companies actually that already
had some scripts in r that they used to
do part of their uh checks and controls
so at this point it was still
balanced but then the question was there
who will be a best fit for
production CU of course the system had
to run in uh
production and if people hear production
python can have a slight Edge so it was
already approved by the IT department as
a a valid uh use for uh
production and they also had already
developers inhouse at the Belgian
justice department who then could manage
that system uh but if you looked at the
existing systems uh so that was among
others a data processing system uh they
did not extend easily for this monitor
case so the things that were needed for
the monitoring could not be provided by
the system as it was running in Python
already so that would have uh to
change plus also if new use cases um uh
came up there were doubts if that system
could be extended to tackle all of those
uh use
cases um but yeah we still had python as
the only option for uh
production then we had a good look at
what they meant by production because
there the opinions can also differ uh if
you ask data scientists and I think Joe
Chen had a good article about this they
say that production is if you have real
users using your app where there are
real consequences if things uh go wrong
and it's using real
data that's
production it has a different view it he
has a view of well if it's production
then there can be no users logging into
the
system there can be no access to any
terminal executing any commands that's
not allowed and you shall not install
things on the Fly you shall not pass it
had this uh really strict requirement of
keeping something in production where
not a lot of things were allowed I think
that's very recognizable for a lot of uh
data science cases that uh that struggle
and so here we faced it as well uh but
then we had a good look at the side of
production that we really needed just
real users with real consequences and
real
data uh and for that we didn't need to
be in the production environment as it
saw it um and then we proposed a uh
platform strategy for
production where uh we looked at systems
that provided Enterprise level support
so that not all the load was on um the
IT department of actually keeping
everything uh running there's a proven
platform uh that is posit connect and by
introducing that platform we also could
level the question again our versus
python as both could uh be run on this
platform and specifically here the
platform would not have to be deployed
on what it considered the production
environment it could be in a test
environment because from that test
environment there was access to the
production data and that was actually
all what we needed users could access
that uh test environment so we had real
users uh it was the actual monitoring so
with actual uh consequences and using
actual uh data so we did have it that
was not bothered too much if it went
down but as this is not the operational
system actually processing the fins that
was also not that big of a
concern uh and so we did have the most
important thing real users and real uh
data um and the advantage of then
choosing this platform strategy is that
if we um set it up once all future use
cases deploying new things to it could
then happen often without each time
having the discussions again uh with the
IT
department and at this point we are back
at an even battlefield of our vers
versus uh
python if it's even then we can have a
look at if any mediation is possible uh
can't we all just get
along combining RM python in the same
deliverable that could be a strategy so
there are packages that uh follow this
strategy we have great packages like
reticulate R2 Pi where you
can uh in the same thing that you're
making combine uh the languages and in
things like quto notebooks uh or um in
just your R scripts this is actually a
very uh valid strategy where you can use
different cells that have uh different
languages and then use the objects
created in one and the other in a very
flexible uh way uh quto if you're not
using it you should be it's really a
powerful uh framework to deliver all
kinds of things for example
presentations on on posit conf as
well but it was more tricky to combine R
and python in the same code for building
a shiny uh API uh thing and so then
combining it in the same deliverable was
not the best uh approach and so it was
also not seen as the solution in this
case uh
here and then we took a step back at how
do other software systems uh solve this
and you actually have a lot of uh
patterns Frameworks approaches
methodologies that are general for
software development but for uh data
science sometimes it feels like new
strategies um but just splitting your
software into different components
modules sometimes micros Services uh if
you're Netflix or somebody like that but
just the splitting your architecture in
multiple components that's actually also
a way that you combine uh multiple uh
programming uh Frameworks in a good uh
good
way and I think um posit also has a very
good documentation on this there's on
their website the bike prediction case
where you have a more elaborate
architecture that has uh ETL um steps
where there's quto documents or markdown
documents that uh uh connect to some
Source data perform some Transformations
and publish uh clean data sets with the
pins package uh who then also run a quto
document to train machine learning model
on that uh pin data set also publish
that model uh in a plumber API and then
using that API in a a shiny
application and so with something like
connect you can actually build these
more elaborate architectures but just on
the same uh platform and then dividing
your uh use case into multiple uh little
pieces that are easier uh to manage
easier to maintain easier to make uh
changes easier also to um yeah let
evolve and get new people on board and
contributing to uh your architecture and
I think it's a Well very well documented
uh solution where they have the source
code all the steps that they do so
definitely something to uh to check
out and it's also the strategy that we
ultimately uh chose for the crossb
monitoring architecture so the
monitoring of the traffic fins where on
posit connect we could use uh our shiny
as our monitoring
dashboard which then connects to a
monitoring API that was built in uh
python that uses the results of uh ETL
that is also running in Python and
actually for the checks uh it made sense
to uh have some checks written in Python
some checks written in R um and then
combine all of these things into a very
efficient and performant uh monitoring
architecture so this way we can reach uh
a verdict and I think as you all
expected probably it wasn't the story
about our or python it's actually the
story of R and uh python where using
them together uh we could make real
speed uh in making Innovation and
efficiency uh possible for the Belgian
uh justice
department um I think there's a lot of
things that data science here can learn
from the classical uh software
architecture and how to approach these
kinds of
architectures and also for me the data
science um can have more broad
applications and just the top high-end
machine learning uh cases I think in a
business context there's a lot of things
that where data play an important role
where the focus is more on the analysis
rather than the the process so I don't I
don't think we'll ever see uh a traffic
fine processing system built in r or
python but there's a lot of things
around it that can be more data driven
and I think this monitoring case is a a
very relevant one where you have anomaly
detection where there are some
algorithms that can help but just the
full endtoend uh architecture where you
have real users using an application
that gets uh warnings and alerts and
they can have a very small workflow it's
a very good case for uh data science and
R and
Python and I think in this case uh the
verdict was reached by the Belgian
justice system so from now on no more
discussions of r or python but it's a
question of R and
python thank you very much for your
attention thank you so much we have a
few questions for you um the first one
is did reticulate give you any headache
when deploying apps that use both R and
python on code not in this case but in a
lot of cases uh it it has indeed uh it's
can be a bit tricky to uh to set it up
correctly um and I think if you have
cases where you can use some R code and
python code that don't have to exchange
to many objects then it can work uh
perfectly if it comes tightly interwoven
it can give headaches yes that's true uh
one more question uh do you have a view
on plumber for apis in R versus the
abundance of python API libraries like
flask or fast API yeah so in in this
case we actually chose uh flask uh as
the
API and in a lot of cases I think python
does have an edge and I think the fast
API for example is a very very uh
powerful uh API framework I think uh
plumber has the advantage of it's easy
for our users to also get started uh and
there's also uh if if there's a lot of R
stuff happening in your API then plumber
makes more sense so for example if you
would have our Marr documents that you
need to generate it makes more sense to
keep within the r framework use plumber
to to generate uh uh that document and I
think the cases where we used it uh
there is some uh consider consideration
in terms of how to scale it um but then
if you have something like the r Studio
or the connect platform there's ways to
control how many users uh Target the
same plumber API at the same time uh and
if you use it for example like in a
cloud context on um Azure for example
you have Azure container apps where you
can also scale your PL plumber app so
that downside doesn't have to be really
a downside so I think for me it's more
about what is does the API do and is
there something specific with r then use
uh plumber and otherwise I think python
does have an edge with fast API yes
thank you so much we can give one more
round of
[Applause]
applause